one thing's for sure it's the economy
stupid that'll once again dominate this
election and let's be clear the wealth
of the city and the flow of money
affects the health of the nation but
this is a complex relationship
Westminster and the city politics and
money global financial markets how
Westminster enthralled during the last
general election campaign with the need
to cut the deficit paramount and in the
blame game the finger was pointed firmly
at bankers and millionaires politicians
tried to regulate and tax them without
killing the Golden Goose now what the
city craves most from Westminster its
clarity and stability we can't stand
uncertainty it has a price so we like to
see firm strong government making
decisions I think banks have got to be
very simple in the way that they go
about business complexity has caused
fear has caused mistrust there are
enormous public sector deficits and
Pensions they need to be tackled to
think we need a new airport and we need
a third runway and we need a second
runway at Gatwick let's for goodness
sake invest in in air travel it's
absolutely the key that tears to the
rest of the world Westminster has had
this sort of schizophrenic relationship
with that the city and the banking
sector generally the financial
institutions more generally too we have
seen growth but that growth has been
very unbalanced that what you want is
people to be earning more to pay more
taxes corporations to make more profits
and pay taxes here in the UK and you can
only really do that if you're growing in
your able to rebalance the economy to
more productive sectors but what works
best for the city and big business may
not necessarily work best for ordinary
folk for politicians at election time
what matters is not so much official
statistics and global economic
performance but what it all means for
the voters in terms of wages prices and
public services the city being a big
group of people towards the bottom of
the income distribution roughing the
bottom third and particularly those of
working at it who have been hit hard by
cuts to Social Security and that's not
surprising they're the people who get no
Social Security the bigger picture is
that there's also group right at the
very top of the distribution have also
been hit very very hard by
number of tax changes now of course if
you're very rich that might feel less
severe than the similar take away from
people lower down the income
distribution but there has been quite
widespread pain as a safe so it's a
balancing act from spending cuts to
taxation stimulating growth yet tackling
the deficit how much pain are we
prepared to endure to get our economy
back on track five years ago after the
last election and outgoing minister
famously left a note good luck there is
no money well there still isn't any
money and that's the biggest challenge
facing the next government what to do in
terms of the mix of public spending cuts
and tax increases here are some trees I
think a lot of politicians think that
money grows on it I really do I mean
they're in there they're talking about
spin spin spin spin spin no one ever
talked about earning it and it's not
popular to say we've got to get behind
business we've had a business secretary
for five years I've never heard him once
a profit is good it wasn't for the
wealth creation process you do not get
public sector spending period because
there is no money to spend if business
doesn't create it from big business a
small business to you and me it's the
power of money that matters not just how
we save it and how we spend it but it's
direct influence on politics that is the
hard reality of this election whatever
they tell you over the next 100 days